[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Ross chunker is with us CBS Westwood one
color analyst he was on the call at the
Buffalo Bills and the Miami Dolphins
um it was a great listen
you were great thanks Dan that coming
from you no you that that means that
that means a heck of a lot I really
appreciate I enjoyed it obviously ended
up being a much better game than I
anticipated and certainly when it was 17
nothing during the commercial breakdown
I'm sitting there thinking oh boy it's
gonna be one of those days uh where the
second half's gonna be a blowout but
Dolphins kept it close it was probably
the longest NFL game I've ever called I
think it was four hours at one point I
literally sit on the air Dan it was
three o'clock and it wasn't halftime yet
I was like what is going on right now
yeah and you start to wonder oh do I
have stories to fill and what are we
going to talk about and then all of a
sudden now did Miami stay in the game or
did Buffalo allowed Miami to stay in the
game
I think it's more the latter I really do
I think it's more the bills turnovers
which is why I have a tough time
picturing them going to the Super Bowl
and winning it yeah you know this has
been consistent for them and honestly
Dan it's a lot of Josh Allen he is
phenomenal he's so entertaining he might
be my favorite quarterback to watch he
made some ridiculous plays again
yesterday but he consistently does not
take care of the football whether it's
interceptions or he fumbles a lot yeah I
think he hits almost five times against
the Dolphins in two games coming into
this one obviously they you know they
recover a bunch of them but he's he's
loosey-goosey with the ball and so that
doesn't mean it'll happen against the
Bengals right they might beat the
Bengals but they got to win three more
to win the whole thing and it kind of
feels like in at least one of those
three Josh Allen will probably have a
couple turnovers that will be the
difference in that game I mean the one
intercept option was horrific you know
the fumble was really bad because he saw
he saw Eric Rowe coming and then that
ends up being a touchdown the Bill's
turnovers are what let the dolphins stay
in the game Talking to Ross Tucker his
uh podcast is Ross Tucker football
podcast yeah I'm wondering about that
and I I haven't been on Buffalo's uh you
know train
in the last two years because it just
feels like they asked Josh Allen to do
an awful lot you almost have to play a
perfect game if you're going to win a
Super Bowl you just can't have those
those Ebbs and flows that he has but I
think that's just because they don't
have a running attack
um he probably tries to do too much
there
I thought they were going to be like
we're gonna blow you out inspirational
Demar Hamlin will be up on the Jumbotron
like you know Dolphins don't have two uh
and it felt that way and then all of a
sudden Miami crept back in it I'm
wondering about this as the Dolphins
move forward they said that to us
they're gonna have Tua come back next
year it's an obvious answer now because
they can't be honest about it but do you
think that Tua is the starting
quarterback for the Dolphins next year I
do yeah I do I you know he's just so
inexpensive Dan compared to what anybody
else they would try to get would cost
you know he's making the his fourth year
of his rookie contract it's very
affordable and I think people lost sight
of this a little bit he led the NFL in
yards per attempt he led the NFL in
quarterback rating I mean Tua had a
fantastic year are there concerns about
his concussion history absolutely there
has to be they have to get a backup
quarterback that can play I think by the
way that was a disappointment what they
got out of Teddy Bridgewater this year I
mean he started two games as a backup as
a highly paid backup he didn't finish
either one of them and then Teddy wasn't
able to play the last two games because
of his pinky so they had to go with the
rookie Skylar Thompson I think I think
Teddy Bridgewater was a disappointment
as a backup quarterback so yes I think
Tua is the starter they hope that he can
protect himself they hope the concussion
stuff since he didn't play these last
couple games he gets the whole offseason
to heal that he'll be okay next year but
they better have a pretty darn good
viable option a backup
let's go through the teams that lost now
we just mentioned the Raven or the uh
let's go the Ravens we just mentioned
the Dolphins who's the starting
quarterback for the Ravens next season
I think Lamar Jackson on the franchise
tag is going to be the starting
quarterback would be my guess I don't
see how the Ravens just let him walk I
mean I would imagine they franchise tag
them one way or the other they either
franchise tag him and he plays for them
for one more year franchise tag him and
sign him to a long-term deal or if it
gets acrimonious then if he's not happy
about it then franchise tag him and
trade him somewhere else I was thinking
about that watching last night watching
Snoop Huntley play pretty well and move
the ball pretty well I was thinking I
wonder what the Ravens front office is
thinking right now but even that he's
not as good as Lamar there's still a
significant difference between them I
think they want him to be there he's
just asking for a contract that the
Ravens cannot do Dan they can't do it
he's missed at least five games last
couple years with his style of play you
cannot give him a five-year fully
guaranteed contract and I think we might
have talked about this last week to Sean
Watson playing the way he did at the end
of the year isn't doing Lamar or any of
these guys any favors to try to get
those type of contracts the head coach
of the Chargers next year will be
probably Brandon Staley
but
I would strongly consider moving on
strongly there's so many red flags to me
I mean you know this other people might
not care about this that much Dan but
but you you'll get what I'm saying here
okay okay you wanted to have your got
your Starters play against the Broncos
none of us understood that but that's
what you wanted to do after the game
when he was asked about it Dan he said
well we only have 48 guys that can dress
for the game we don't have enough
backups so this is what things that
really bother me Brandon if you're gonna
make a decision like that
at least have a better logic or
reasoning don't tell us after the game
well there's not enough uh roster spots
the Giants Brian dabel didn't play his
eight best players against the Eagles
and and even if that's your argument why
did Herbert play till five minutes left
in the fourth quarter so and then later
on the week when Mike Williams didn't
practice okay and they said aren't you
worried that Mike Williams missing reps
he said not really this part of the Year
rest is more important than reps he said
it four days after he had those guys
play in the game so I think the Chargers
are going to consider it but are you
going to get rid of him without knowing
for sure that you have a better option
that's the thing if they fire Brandon's
daily it'll be like two weeks from now
when behind the scenes they get a paid
or they get somebody that they are
confident is better well that's the key
if you say well we don't want to have
him as our head coach then who's the
upgrade over Brandon Staley if you don't
get Sean Payton or I guess Jim Harbaugh
I don't know if he has any ties to the
Chargers but if you don't get that
significant upgrade then you're not
going to make that decision speaking of
the Chargers and the Jags you want to
give America your stat of the day on
Trevor Lawrence
is that me yeah
I I don't know didn't you didn't you
tweet out that he hasn't lost a game oh
what are you doing
Dan sorry yes I didn't know that was my
status today it's a full start by you no
you don't even get the music now it's a
false start I you sent it and you're
like you're so proud of it Mr Saturday
night Trevor Lawrence has never lost a
game on a Saturday now I want to know
how many high school games he played on
Saturday although by the way like he
should never have lost a high school
game and then those two games he lost at
Clemson neither one of them was a
Saturday I don't even remember that but
yes
I stole that from somebody else I don't
know who I stole from I stole it from
somebody else so I didn't really look at
his my stat of the day but thank you all
right they don't play high school games
on Saturday they play on Friday his two
losses in high school were on Fridays
his two College losses were on a Monday
and a Friday
he's never lost a game on a Saturday
oh my gosh I just realized Saturday he
can keep that streak going you you
talked over the music that what status
yeah you butchered that
sorry yeah hope you're happy uh I guess
Daniel Jones and saquon Barkley earned
uh contracts everybody's all in on those
two guys long-term contracts is that
I'll make you uh the GM of the Giants
what are you doing with those two guys
now I think you have to I mean look
there's always a number right I mean
there's some point where the the money's
too much and maybe you don't do it but
they also have to pay they have to pay
Dexter Lawrence too I mean John Mara is
going to have an unprecedented opening
of the checkbook this off season it's
funny you go from then where it's like
they didn't want to extend those guys
because they weren't sure
now I guess it's a good problem to have
but now it's like oh crap we got to pay
all three of these guys we can't let I
mean that's maybe our best defensive
player our best offensive weapon and our
quarterback who's playing really well
but that's like I said that's a good
problem to have
how was the Bill's tailgate
so good so good so I Saturday night I
met up with some of my podcast listeners
at uh bar Bill Tavern probably the best
wings I've ever had
like Cajun honey barbecue honey barbecue
I mean just
I ca I haven't had that many wings since
like college
it was amazing did you drink beer
Dan
it was a Saturday night in America and I
was in Buffalo yes of course I drank
beer absolutely I did there's always
that fine line though because it's a one
o'clock game so it's like you can
appreciate this how many beers can you
have and enjoy yourself but like not
jeopardize your voice your performance
the next day
I went out with Nick Mangold one time in
New York City Jets offensive lineman
yeah and uh we were ordering beers and
he he ordered a pitcher and I thought
the picture was for the table
he drank out of the pitcher while we
were drinking beers and he was just
holding a picture like it was a mug and
I went okay I got respect for that got
him so I think I posted on Instagram but
I'll put somewhere else I had a picture
with two pictures like that I know I was
pouring it into a glass okay but I had I
I was rocking the Le Bat Blue Light
that's my that's my Buffalo beer for my
playing days uh who do you got tonight
um
so I think the move is okay if we're
talking betting I think the move is
to take the cow I mean I'm sorry the
Bucks up to eight and a half
pair it with the Chiefs down to two and
a half
in a two team six point teaser because
right now the Chiefs are favored by
eight and a half so you move them both
six points you get the bucks plus eight
and a half I love it you get the Chiefs
minus two and a half I love it if we're
just talking straight up money line or
even laying the two and a half I think
I'm laying it with the Cowboys they're
the better team man I mean look it'll be
it'll be interesting tomorrow if the
Cowboys can't even beat the Bucks can't
even win ah playoff game okay this year
more likely to change coaches if the
Cowboys lose tonight or what happened to
the Chargers
Cowboys lose tonight I think if the
Cowboys lose tonight Mike McCarthy will
be done and I think Jerry Jones will go
hard for Sean Payton and probably get
him I really I really think tonight if
McCarthy wins tonight I think pretty
good chance he keeps the job if he loses
tonight I mean Dan Jerry Jones not a
spring chicken you know he's not getting
any younger I think he wants to take one
more big run at this they've got a
pretty talented team and if McCarthy
can't even win this one tonight I think
I think he'll do everything he can to
get Sean Payton into Dallas better job
for Sean Payton if the jobs were open
the Chargers or the Cowboys
well there's a lot of interesting
Dynamics there because let's talk about
the power structure and let's talk about
how much control he has because I think
I I know Sean likes La I think he likes
Dallas
I think it will come down to money a
little bit but I think more it might be
how much say he has right like how much
control he has over the Personnel
because he had a lot of control in New
Orleans I think he's a lot more likely
to get that probably with the Chargers
but it'll probably come down to that
just feel like he has more control over
the process thank you bud talk to you
absolutely thank you talk to you next
week that's yep a good buddy Ross Tucker
if you're looking to turn a small bed
into a big payday draftking Sportsbook
same game parlays you can pocket more
cash when you combine multiple bets from
one game download the app sign up use
the code Patrick that's draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details